in Washington the financial and
political elite are sticking with their
clear message to Greece additional
financial aid is only available in
exchange for reforms US President Barack
Obama agrees the debt-ridden country
needs to do more recent EADS to initiate
reforms they have to collect taxes they
have to reduce their bureaucracy they
have to have more flexible labor
practices these are the demands Greece's
creditors have repeated for months and
Athens is yet to fulfill them here in
Washington no one's expecting a quick
compromise but that's what Greece needs
nearly three months after its new
government took office the country's
disastrous finances haven't improved
this month it's unclear where the
government workers and pensioners will
be paid as usual the status is running
out of cash definitely the scrubbing
crash from where ago they can and they
can find it right now but I think we
were given enough liquidity to keep all
but the process we can enjoy the end of
the day you're gonna need a new deal and
if it's not given over that then yes
we're gonna run off funny Athens sees
partnering with Russia as one option
Greek Prime Minister Alexis tsipras met
with Russian President Vladimir Putin in
early April Spiegel Online is now
reporting that the two governments plan
to sign an energy Accord in the coming
days it would see Athens cooperate on a
pipeline intended to carry Russian gas
from the Black Sea coast to Europe it's
not expected to operate before 2019 but
an advance payment on the pipeline's
profits could send up to five billion
euros Greece's way that would give
Greece some breathing room in its
negotiations with creditors good news
for the country but Brussels won't look
on its growing ties with moscow
favorably